I do feel like when I'm at work when I'm
on set when I'm like doing a show that
is probably where I'm the most myself
um because I love it and I work hard at
it and I'm ready when I get there like I
have a exhaustive sort of prep process
and then I throw it all away once I'm on
set and I'm just there so are you saying
that there's sort of a juxtaposition of
like you're on set that's your world of
confidence but in the real world maybe
you're not as you know I think I'm not
as with the like publicity side of it
and doing interviews and like the Press
support you have to do for projects why
is that you think you know it just feels
like a different kind of attention on
you it feels like much more pressure it
feels like
um more personal I guess and when you're
playing a character you are you get to
hide behind that and like you're acting
and it's